how are you guys doing with everything
that's going on and what do you make of
everything I think we're doing pretty
good yeah yeah keep him busy yeah what
are you guys doing to pass the time as a
family I mean I love that you're all
quarantined together we've been
organizing a lot a lot of house yeah
doing chores around the house like
cleaning like that kind of stuff yeah
yeah every day yeah yeah more baking so
we're baking what do you guys baking
cookies cakes yeah just kind of basic
stuff we're not very good at it yeah I
don't believe you I feel like this
family right here is good at everything
especially your tic TOCs there and in a
way yes I mean I feel like more people
than ever are on tic toc right now yes
which is why Charlie I love that you're
gonna be doing this distance dance thing
what can you tell us about this so I
partnered with P&G to help spread the
message that staying home is extremely
Brit and social discipline sake and
making sure you're keeping yourself seen
as well as everyone else only go out and
you really really have to and just
making sure that you're keeping everyone
in mind and really just trying to help
people and spread the message that it's
so important to stay home and just
trying to relay that to as many people
as I can yeah I mean I love that you're
using your platform for that how can
people participate in this so I'm
actually going to teaching the dance
this Friday on an Instagram live so I'll
be teaching it there and just making
your own hosts of the distance dance and
trying to spread that message as much as
possible tag me and hashtag distance
dance
to try to just relay the message as much
as we can throughout to talk and post it
on Instagram Twitter all that stuff just
making sure that we're getting the
message out as much as we can
yeah I love that what can you tell us
about what you have up your sleeve for
Friday I mean it's a family gonna be
participating or the dog is gonna be
around you
the dogs are always around there's no
question about that so I'm super excited
it should be a lot of fun yeah when you
say special guests do you mean other
celebrities are we gonna hang out with
yellow again virtually what do you have
planned yes definitely lots of other
people that you might not expect but
you'll be happy with everything's all
put together is it gonna be like a new
dance that you're gonna be teaching a
new one that you've made up are they are
we gonna learn like renegade through you
um so we'll definitely be doing the
distance dance Besant is all about but
it'll just be one big dance party new
whatever anyone wants to see yeah I mean
it is it's really great that you are
using your platform for this like to
spread such a needed message right now
especially to youth to understand like
the importance of staying home but I do
want to talk about your platform because
you are about to hit 50 million
followers on tick-tock yeah it's wild
right I mean you're the most followed
person right now on tick-tock how does
that feel how did you celebrate
so we pretty much celebrate almost every
milestone that I hit pretty well so what
we did I don't think we celebrated
number maybe more sweeping I think I was
sleeping when it happened so like
anything Marcin happened it's what she's
doing good this means you soon but once
I found out I mean it feels awesome
but I think it's truly about just being
able to have the platform that I have to
be able to describe messages like this I
mean it's crazy to go from zero
followers to 40 something million I
don't know but it's really crazy yeah I
mean people love you and they also love
your entire family I mean your guys's
family account has a time
Dixey you have like 20 million I think
we just moving this something to be so
proud of I mean how do you guys kind of
soak this in and what's next for your
family I feel like right now like since
we had a lot of free time we're just
preparing of why do we start getting
busy again because it was very hectic
before but now we've had like a lot of
times just like bigger game plants and
how we're going to produce content and
share a family more general and
personalities through other platforms
besides
[Music]